upstate new york uh restaurant owner on
chicken shortages
wing costs skyrocketed nearly 100 fox
business story wing shortage our latest
problem to plague
uh poultry producers who are who have
struggled to keep up with the demand
that have skyrocketed with the reopening
of the economy and due to a number of
fast food chains have recently
introduced chicken sandwiches
the lower mississippi based sanderson
farms inc the country's third largest
poultry producer said it does not have
enough supply to keep up with demand
despite recently picking up 40 million
pounds per year last month joe anderson
ceo of sanderson's farms
set up the goldman sachs global staples
forum that his company each week ends up
short 15 loads of wings for both retail
and food services the company plans to
allocate wings to make sure everybody
gets some
he said noting that the combination of
strong demand and limited supplies will
cause prices to climb
even higher from current levels danielle
and sanderson put itself up for sale is
that what it is
they did yeah i mean they're striking
while the iron's hot look
my my respect my my hat's off to the guy
who like started a whole and
you will love this patrick there's a guy
who started a whole
company based on thighs dice thighs he
was he was interviewed yesterday he was
like look
wings wings used to be unloved we export
all of our thighs to the rest of the
world damn it let's make thighs
bring thighs back we know the dark dark
meat tastes good so
he's he's starting a whole company based
on make thighs great again
are you is it ties or breaths i mean i'm
a thigh guy i could die i'm never going
to do it you know
we were going there you set us up i mean
it was unfair that was just too easy of
a setup right so you're like you're
you're
you're an equal opportunity
danielle as an economist as an economist
we all respect is this just another case
example of supply and demand what is
this
it is an example of supply and demand i
mean look you had like
you had orange juice prices going
through the roof and then all of a
sudden
the weather forecasts change and then
they come down supply will
meet demand look at what's happened in
louisiana
in georgia you've got all these sawmills
up and running that hadn't been
up and running for for a generation so
all of a sudden you've got lumber prices
coming down
because supply is coming on to meet the
demand
by the way on the on the uh on the ratio
of the bitcoin
yep it's 54 to 18. two thirds
66 believe one million thirty three
percent believe
one thousand we have a bitcoin
bitcoin is also perceived to be by a lot
of people who don't understand it a
simple refutation of fiat money
they're like they're like they're
driving the dollar into the ground sure
they're printing money i've been told
that bitcoin's a hedge
that's why i own it and so for people
who don't appreciate the national debt
clock for
a lot of them that's reason enough
with this wing thing just to get a
little recap i don't think that this
wing thing and the side thing and your
breast manner or leg man
i think just just put it on it's not
that big of a deal right now
because we're not in football season if
it's football season and there's no
wings
at your local wing at your local sports
bar now you're going to have a problem
so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye